why do your team not have targets if I
look at myself I was never overly
motivated by targets I definitely wanted
to be top of the board that was really
important to me but targets less so and
I think targets can also lead to
complacency if you're working with
people that are very intrinsically
motivated and have clear personal goals
like if someone has a personal goal of
being Financial free at a certain age I
don't have to give them a Target because
they're just looking at that personal
goal calculating back exactly what they
need to do then trying to achieve that
goal that's the reason we're not doing
it I wouldn't necessarily recommend it
to every company it works for our
organization because we hire people that
have quite a bit of experience and
maturity and I only hire people that are
highly intrinsically motivated so
therefore it's not really a requirement
for us